[Music]  that was a terrible crash  well lucky to be alive  who are you  it's so loud here we call it the noise  happened to all the men on this planet  every thought in our heads  we're on display  where are all the women  they're dead  [Music]  why is she thinking where the hell is  her noise it's strange to see everything  you're thinking it was strange for me  too not knowing what's going on in your  head  i mean i know you might not like my dog  or you want to hit me over the head with  a rock or something  i like your dog he's stronger than he  knows  you better watch your noise snake snake  those men catch it they'll kill you  if you want to protect the girl you have  to leave now  keep you safe safe with her power  there's no telling what he can do  i leave that girl before she wants him  how many are coming 100  200 thousands  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you